l'esprit français est habité par l'idée
que le volontarisme en politique résout
tous les problèmes en temps de paix les
acteurs économiques doivent être
dominant et l'État doit être à leur
service c'est une idée à laquelle nous
n'accédons pas en France c'est plutôt
une idée anglo-saxone des penseurs
actuel comme ERC Zemour sont très
hostiles à cette idée ERC Zemour va vend
500000 livres moi si j'en vends 5000 je
serais content voyez un peu le rapport
de force comment il est déséquilibré et
c'est pour cette raison l'esprit
politique français fabriqué par le
souven de Louis X de Napoléon et de du
général de Gaul quand on fait de la
politique en France madame c'est pour
renverser le monde et bien ça ça
n'entraîne que des déception moi si un
jour je suis élu président de la
République savez-vous quelle est la
première mesure que je prendrai je
raserai le château de versaill vous êtes
pas prêt d'être élu he je peux vous le
garantir ce serait ma mesure numé vousz
êtes tranquille vous resterez
journaliste ser mesure numéro 1 pour que
nous n'allion pas là-bas en pèlerinage
cultiver la grandeur de la France
devenons réaliste